hi everyone thank you for joining us
for today's presentation entitled highly
multiplexed
digital spatial profiling of the tumor
micro environment
of head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
patients
treated with immune checkpoint therapy
it's my real pleasure to introduce you
to arutha
kulasinga he's a peter doherty nhmic
early
career fellow at the queensland
university of technology
here in australia for a complete bio of
aruta and all our speakers please visit
the tab at the bottom of your screen
now if you have any questions during the
presentation please submit them in the q
a box there on your screen
and our speaker will respond back to you
via email
so please join me in welcoming ruther
i'll turn the presentation over to him
hello everyone so my name is arith
kulasingha i'm an nhmrc early career
research fellow from the queensland
university of technology and i'll be
talking about some of my
spatial proteomics work
and neck cancer patients that received
immune checkpoint therapy
so this work started off so my
background is in in
looking at circulating tumor cells so
these are transient metastatic
cells or metastatic precursor cells that
are found in the blood of
um solid tumor patients they're
typically found as single cells or salt
clusters and i was really interested in
these um
rare cell populations in the blood and
um
obviously they go on to form distant
metastases in the lungs liver
and brain so we used a number of
approaches to capture these circulating
tumor cells as described in slide
here including positive selection so we
used the
fda approved webcam enrichment
technology as well as negative depletion
to capture these rare cells
we also looked at filtration-based
devices and microfluidic
devices to capture these red cells from
a blood sample
and these are some of the technologies
we looked at and
we looked at the plasma as well for
clinically actionable mutations
so when we were characterizing these
circulating tumor cells and phenotyping
then we found that pdl1 was frequently
expressed in these head and neck um
samples and that was really interesting
to us and we wanted to look at it in a
bit
more depth and we also uh performed
x-vivo culture
in a number of these samples
so this is one of the key slides where
we found that in circulating tumor cells
bdl1 was frequently expressed and
it was it was expressed in head and neck
and non-small cell lung cancer and this
is compared to a number of cell lines
obviously pdl1 is dynamically expressed
in the tumor so
we wanted to find a more realistic or
real-time snapshot
of the pdl1 expression in in ctcs and we
thought that this might be a way in
which to do that
and this is just some survival metrics
at the bottom right hand corner showing
that
patients with ctcs had a poorer overall
survival
in head and neck and launched most of
the lung cancer
so that's i think the time when jim
allison's work came out and
the working city and the science papers
that came out showed that
in in a certain subset of patients they
did really well with the immune
checkpoint therapy
and this was really driven by melanoma
but head and neck and non-small cell
lung cancer as you can see
were in that were a subset of patients
that
benefited from this therapy so
because we were working in this space i
really wanted to go back and look at the
tumor
of these patients and see what was going
on not just at the pdl1 expression level
of p1
levels but um other microenvironment
cells as well so there were a number of
biomarkers in this space and tmb
autino mutation button was one of them
so on this scale here you can see that
head and neck and not small cell lung as
i said in the
sort of midpoint of this uh
of this graph and high tmb for head and
neck is about 10.3
megabases per mutations per megabase or
more
and then this is being refined at the
moment and it's sort of being led by
melanoma
and the data in the first line setting
there for head and neck it is given in
the metastatic setting but there is um
it is now being looked at in in
recurrent uh
head and neck patients in the first line
setting
so this comes on to the tumor micro
environment work that i'll be talking
about in this uh
greater depth and actually looking at
this spatially and then getting that
level of
depth of information not just um
expression data at the global
scale but you know in looking at
different regions within this human
micro environment was really really key
to moving this work forward
and we were able to do that using the
nano string uh digital spatial profiler
in
a pilot study and we're expanding this
work at the moment so
really looking at the micro environment
versus the tumor stroma
and then comparing it to normal regions
to see what was driving these cells
[Music]
so this is some of the therapies that
are given for
head and neck um over the progression of
it over over time and you can see that
in the in in in the mid to early 2000s
when pdo1 was found to be overexpressed
in
tissues and then there was um iterations
of
pembro and nevo that came out in late
last couple years and then where the
field is heading
um now with with a number of
immunotherapies being developed in this
space
so this is the technology we use to to
profile a number of head and neck
tissue samples from patients that
received io therapy they were recruited
to checkmate studies
and it was a preliminary study so i'm
sure the audience is aware of this
technology so
um their antibody so we looked at the
proteins
initially and now we're doing the rna
so we looked at the protein target so we
we were interested in in profiling these
two uh these tumors using the
40 plex i mean oncology panel from
nanospring
where the antibodies bind to a uv for
the cleavable oligo
and when regions of interest are chosen
this
the signal is liberated and they can and
that can be counted
and there's a number of different uh
data normalization so i think this is a
key slide for a lot of this work it
it it i think it speaks to
a lot of this new technology and then
single cell sequencing and then the data
normalization is becoming increasingly
challenging but i think there are ways
in which we can
uh better assess our data so there are a
number of different ways to start it
with normalized so ercc normalization
nucleus normalization area normalization
and number of housekeepers include and
signal to noise normalization
for each data set so we were able to
measure across the rois
and uh within the roi if there were
tumor or stroma
so these are a number of just a snapshot
of what we do
we get an h and e section this is
assessed by pathologists to demarcate
the tumor and normal region
we try to do whole exome sequencing on
these tumors but there was there were
limitations with how much dna was
available from them from
from one of them we were able to um get
enough dna to do a whole exome and then
that patient
had 5.7 mutations to megabase so
this is your typical hme stain on the
top and then
in the middle what we can see is a
visualization mark is stained by the dsp
and the stained and imaged by the dsp
for pan cider keratin cd3
cd8 and daby where we would then compare
that staining to the h e and then choose
regions of interest so you can see a
number of regions of interest
for these it was 12 regions of interest
per
tissue section and then on the
corresponding slide below those are the
regions of interest at a higher
magnification so we did this for eight
tumors
uh h8 h and scc
head and next from the cell carcinoma
tumors
so this is a high resolution image of of
one of them so you can see that this has
been stained with pancetta keratin cd3
cd8 and dapi
and then these 12 regions of interest
are selected and then those
are profiled at 40 plex so the
visualization markers are key
to choose what you want to profile so
ideally you'd want to do more if you
could
so i think we are looking at doing 24
and expanding this out even more
so this is just some of the data um from
a head and neck patient that was
t4 0 and 0 left mandible p16 negative so
hpv negative
this patient had multiple rounds of
chemo radiation and surgery and was
given immunotherapy certain volume up in
the metastatic setting
so we had the diagnostic biopsy tissue
we profiled it using the dsp
looked at 12 regions of interest across
the tumor the normal dystroma
and this was just a snapshot of at the
bottom the graph just shows the
variation
in individual markers
per region of interest so we can see
whether uh
tumor-rich region is high inside a
keratin or
just together to understand whether the
essay worked or not initially before we
go into
um the the multi-market work and the
panel of antibodies we looked at are on
the right hand side here so there's a
number of controls a number of
housekeepers
um and it and the rest of the markets
for an immune activation immune cell
profiling
io drug targets so a number of novel
markers as well in the sting
vista idea one which are really
interesting markers i think in the io
space
and some pan tumor markers as well
and we're able to do this across
multiple
tissue sections and generate heat maps
um
essentially for each tissue section so
we're able to measure a tumor signature
an immune signature and then
infiltrating edge or a mixed signature
where there is overlap between
tumor and immune regions together and
just to get an idea of what cells are
there
and and then mark expression levels
and we're able to do this from about 20
microns all the way up to 400 microns it
depends on on what your region of
interest
is and what you're looking at whether
it's in the global level or you want to
go down into the
um sort of the you know 10 cells or
profile 20 cells at a time
and this is just a snapshot of of of
what we're able to do this is a 40
as measured across this one just showing
different expression levels
um just to see what sort of data we're
able to get
and on the right what we see is the
variation
in three um
three markers which are being looked at
in diameter space of vista sting in idea
one and you can see the variation
across three um head and neck tissues
so they're involved in um immune
regulation and and we're trying to look
at this in greater depth so not just the
pd1 pdl one but
but what about the other markers and
then spatially where is vista express
where is thing expressed where is ido1
expressed
and how does that associate with disease
progression
and this is another snapshot of the
variation
across those eight tumors for the tumor
immune and mixed rois and the variation
across those markers going across the
chart there
and in this slide we're able to compare
um
tumor regions um versus immune regions
and see what sort of cells are expressed
especially what cells are within the
tumor
it's not just about the cd8 cells within
the tumor but i think what other cells
are there
i think some of david grimm's work
showed that cd68 cells in the tumor were
predictive in melanoma so i think
you know not just looking at the cd8
cells but what other cells are are
brought in then k
cells what are um the fox p3 cells
could be really interesting so we're
able to compare different regions of
interest and see
what sort of markers are expressed what
sort of immune cells are recruited into
the tumor or excluded from the tumor
and in the bottom we're able to measure
the infiltrating edge
versus a tube versus an immune rich
area as well as the same sort of
analysis just giving us a snapshot of
of the signal within those areas
so validation is always important
and this was quite challenging for us
because we were looking at 50 or 60
i mean oncology markers spatially and
how we could then validate this data so
we looked at
uh using a smaller plex high multiplex
ihc panel so
in this case as well but we built it up
to six markers at the moment
using the uh pokenoma opal staining kit
ck cd8 pdl1 and daffy were done
on similar regions of interest on the
top you can see an h e section
demarcating the
tumor and then that was profiled on the
nanostring and the
opal systems and assessed for similar
regions of interest
um to see how the expression levels
varied and
we were able to find that both systems
were quite concordant with what they
were
um sustaining um across both systems
and this was reaffirming to us and then
we're doing this in in
in greater depth at the moment
so this is somewhat just some analysis
between um
the total set of samples done so
the patient i kind of put pathological
findings are on the left hand side
so two patients received nevo and five
received tempo
pembro in the metastatic setting and we
were able to
compare the marker data um
to survival outcomes so whether they
were progresses
uh whether they were non-progressives
and non-progressives and pd democrats uh
progressive disease
and what was really interesting from
this initial pilot data set was that cd8
cells weren't predictive of outcome and
this sort of goes against the
um current literature but
i think this was interesting because
spatially we could assess this
and what's interesting was on this next
slide we could see that there were a
number of markers that were
predictive of of progressive disease so
cd44
sting cd66
so now we're looking at these markers at
a greater depth and really trying to
understand especially where they are
um and what other cells are recruited
within these regions
and pd1 and pdl one at the top of this
um
and grand sign view
so this is just some preliminary lung
cancer data where
we did a tumor microarray so 92 cases
normal and looked at it on a 60x i o
panel
again protein and what we wanted to do
was to
use the masking function so this is
where you're able to
take the pathologist's demarcation of
the tumor and normal regions and then
you're able to draw
within it so in this um in the bottom
right hand corner you can see that you
can make a tumor mask
and you can liberate the signal off that
and when you do the inverse you get the
tumor micro
environment signal which is you know you
get a total
that you get a total signal per core for
the tumor and the
environment micro environment data this
is what we're trying to attempt with the
with the lung tma and this data is
really really
new um so i'm really excited about this
data
and just some a quick snapshot of what
we're
able to do when we're able to compare
the stroma versus a healthy cell
each core had a match normal tissue as
well and we're able to see the number of
markers that are
highly expressed
which is significantly uh found to be
um present between the healthy and tumor
versus
the stroman tumor as well and vista
comes up again when you compare the
tumor versus the stroma cd44
cd45 so there are a number of markers
here that are highly uh
significant that we're trying to look at
in a greater depth and
at the bottom that's just a heat map
comparing
the the the tumor the stroma and the
matched
paired normal this is really preliminary
data but but it's
really exciting that we're able to do
this from a microarray
and we're hoping to really use that
geomosking function to get uh
two signals or two signatures per core
and then we'd be able to measure it
across the number of tmas
i think this is really powerful in this
case this was a noise non-spola cell
lung cancer
so in summary multispectral spatial
proteomic profiling characterizes the
tumor microenvironment in
hnscc patients with io c8t
cells were not trying to be predictable
come to immune checkpoint therapy
there were a number of other markers cd4
cd68 cd45
44 and 66b were found to associate with
progressive disease in a
preliminary of patients and in one
patient there was a
low intermediate tmb um for
that tissue section and um
so the dsp data revealed increase pd1
and
low pdl1 in the chimaera wires
so comprehensive analysis of the tmb and
spatial tme such a microenvironment may
in combination predict
outcome in the future and these
applications i think can be extended
into ctc analysis and opinoid cultures
if you can get these sections
if you can get those cells on slides and
then you'd be able to profile them so i
think that's a really novel angle that
i'm looking at
as well with that i'd like to
thank you for listening to the talk and
to acknowledge the funding agencies
that contributed to the study as well as
the patients that
gave their valuable samples and i'd like
to thank the team in brisbane that
assisted with this work as well thank
you
arutha thank you that was really
fantastic very exciting talk
we have a number of questions for you
now so the first one is
how were regions of interest chosen in
this study
and is whole slide analysis available
so regions of interest were chosen based
on a pathologist's review
of an h e section and then we would
stain that
section um and visualize it based on
cytokeratin cd8 dappy
and one more color cd3 cd4 and then we
would match that up
against an hd section and then choose
different regions of interest across
tumor normal stroma and
measure that
so another question here relates to kind
of how you use tissues in this analysis
and it's
how do you compare the use of full face
tissue sections versus
tissue microarrays for dsp analysis
which did you prefer and
perhaps you could comment on your
results from those two approaches
i think that's a great question so we
did full face
tissue sections for the head and neck
study
and now we're going into tissue
microarrays
and doing that in the in head and neck
and lung cancer
so i think with tmas you're able to uh
profile a lot more samples
but the full face tissue sections
obviously have their value in that
you're able to get a full
uh appreciation for the tissue section
and not just the core biopsy
arutha i have another question for you
here and it's an important one which is
how do you validate dsp data
so the dsp data was validated using the
opel pakenoma
um a solution so the multiplex ihc
you could do this using imaging mass
spec or just multiplex ifc
and we did it at four plex but you i
think it there's the scope to
increase it to a six plus six plex
essay and ideally you do the same
regions of interest or
as close as possible to see how that
looked
so ruth another question here which is
really kind of asking you to
to discuss the challenges of all
involved in the spatial analysis that
you've described to us today
yeah that's another great question so i
think the challenges in
spatial analysis i think you need to be
really clear about the question that's
being asked
whether it's a clinical question whether
it's a research-based question because
the data that you get back
is extensive and you could be under that
for months
so really knowing what you wanted what
you
want going in will probably dictate what
you uh get coming out and then that's
really important
um going in and i think there's a lot
more
data that comes out of of these sorts of
studies and
they're great for sort of hypothesis
generating and then
and questions like that but really being
specific about the question that you're
asking
is really important because the volumes
of diet you get back would
keep you under for four months on end
and finally aretha your last question is
how did you choose the visualization
markers that you used
for your study
so the visualization markers were chosen
uh based on some simple
uh just some simple stains such as
cytokeratin cd8
fb cd3 or cd4 cells we really just
wanted to demarcate the tumor micro
environment from that of the tumor
and compare that to the hb section and
those are sort of universal markers that
are used
so i think the takeaway message from
from this initial
analysis and this data set was is that
um
digital spatial profiling is a really
powerful technology
but i think we need to be really careful
in in in designing our experiment and
being really careful in
in in choosing what our research
question is because the data sets that
we get out are really really massive
and really being able to sit around and
have a pathologist
on board a clinician on board a number
of scientists on board and being able to
uh you know interrogate that tumor
section or that tissue microarea is key
and
um it's it's it's a really um
exciting space i think and it it will
um likely lead to the clinic a lot of
this work is
is being done with um human specimens so
i think
it's a really powerful technology to
really understand the tumor
microenvironment
and there's a lot of information that we
can
get out of it so initially it was just
you know
cd8 cells excluded from the tumor
regions are there
are they infiltrating the tumor but the
level of depth of information that we
cannot get at the protein level
and and that's not even going into the
the larger panels that are being done at
rna levels such as the cancer
transcriptome atlas work which we're
doing at the moment
and that's really powerful i think going
forward getting the complement of the
rna data plus the protein data
associating that with outcomes
to checkpoint therapies um melanoma head
and neck cancer
non-small cell lung cancer it would be
a powerful um sort of a companion
diagnostic tool
to assist in selecting patients that are
likely to benefit from immune checkpoint
therapy
and in that way target therapies to
those patients that are likely
to receive the greatest benefit
and with that i'd like to thank everyone
for listening to my talk